[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance we have elected an idiot for
all the insanity and the stunning
self-absorption and the bullying and the
delusional view of America that would
embarrass a high school dropout watching
cartoons while strung out on meth the
much more existential threat from the
Swiss cheese personality of Donald John
Trump roared to the forefront over this
weekend past and that existential threat
is simply this in the complex
international relations that like it or
not keep the world from blowing itself
up every afternoon Trump has just proved
he has no earthly clue what the [ __ ] he
is doing just since last Friday Donald
Trump has given aid and comfort to our
Russian enemies who are aiming for
nothing short of world prominence with
the help of their jackass Trump he has
undermined this nation status as the
only enforcer left on the side of human
rights and he has screwed up whether
inadvertently or as reported Sunday
night deliberately nearly four decades
of diplomacy balanced on a Razors Edge
with China and Taiwan and just as that
China and Taiwan diplomacy began to
stabilize he went and screwed it up
again on Twitter good work [ __ ] you
don't have to live next door to the
United Nations to understand why talking
to the president of Taiwan and making it
public and referring to the close
economic political and security ties
between Taiwan and the United States
just increase the chances that Trump
will get some of us including his
supporters killed since 1979 we have
played a silly little childish game with
mainland China if we don't make a big
deal about that island of Taiwan if we
don't call it a nation if we recognize
that psychologically Taiwan is to the
Chinese
what communist Cuba has been to us since
1959 if our diplomats and presidents and
[ __ ] select like Donald Trump don't
rub China's nose in it the Chinese will
not wipe the more-or-less democracy of
Taiwan off the freaking map it's that
simple the 1 billion 350 million
mainland Chinese Communists will not
turn the 23 and a half million Chinese
on Taiwan into a parking lots all we
have to do is not do exactly what Donald
nitwit Trump did by saying what he did
to the Taiwanese president last Friday
but of course he did it because he
thinks he knows better than everybody
else about the world when he doesn't
know [ __ ] and anyway what's the fate of
23 and a half million Chinese on Taiwan
compared to what really matters the
president of Taiwan called me today to
wish me congratulations on winning the
presidency thank you
interesting how the US sells Taiwan
billions of dollars of military
equipment but I should not accept a
congratulatory call because clearly the
point of an incoming presidential
administration is to see how many
leaders around the world call in to tell
them how terrific he is we now see six
weeks out from the inauguration the
outlines of the Trump doctrine
congratulate Trump Sunday a crowded
elevators worth of trumpets pushed a
story in The Washington Post that this
was all planned it was a more robust
defense of Taiwan which is of course
even dumber especially if the idiot
elect has to publicly disguise his
planned robustness as naivete because of
course he then gets mad when people call
him naive and so thus he doubles down on
the whole thing Sunday night on Twitter
so now not only are the Chinese pissed
off not only is there helping whatever
looms next for us in North Korea in
jeopardy and not only is an actual slow
growth in the reliability of the
relationship between our two countries
at risk but who benefits from
uncertainty between the US and China we
don't win from it but Chinese don't win
from it and whose interest is the new
confusion the new setback the new ass
hattery from Trump Russia always Russia
Russia and by the way guess what flooded
out of a WikiLeaks dump Saturday that
you probably didn't hear about 90
gigabytes
2420 documents of intelligence related
to Germany and the German President
Angela Merkel ahead of Germany's
upcoming elections Germany which since
Trump's election by a minor
30 of our voters has already taken our
place as the leading democracy in the
world and the only Western power able
are willing to stand up against the
passive-aggressive World War that Russia
has been waging for several years now
with the aid and comfort a president
elect Donald bumbling amateur Putin
puppet [ __ ] Trump and yes I said
Trump's election has already resulted in
Germany taking our place as the leading
democracy the leading enforcer on the
side of human rights in the world and if
these Fiasco's with China and Taiwan and
WikiLeaks and Germany are not evidenced
enough there was a third Trump
diplomatic disaster that might actually
have eclipsed the other two Philippines
president Rodrigo Duterte the street
thug who has had thousands of his
citizens murdered by police and
vigilantes without trial or in many
cases without even arrest on the pretext
of an anti-drug campaign
Duterte says he too got on the phone
with Trump on Friday and that Trump
endorsed the barbarism duterte has
unleashed I could sense a good rapport
an animated president-elect Trump and he
was wishing me success in my campaign
against the drug problem Duterte said he
understood the way we are handling it we
are many things in this country but we
have never and must never stoop to
murder disguised as law and order by a
dictator who has compared his own
actions to those of Adolf Hitler as if
he were complementing himself worst yet
Duterte said this buffoon Trump has
invited him to visit New York and
Washington and bluntly Rodrigo Duterte
should not be admitted to this country
even in a casket but don't tell Trump
that he knows everything if this is how
this dense pea-brained little man is
going to run things if this is how far
in over his own fat orange head he's
going to be internationally if this is
how he is going to strut as president a
triple chin bull in a nuclear china shop
he cannot be allowed to become president
because after January 20th if he decides
to have a week of prioritizing receiving
congratulations for his inaugural and
tweeting out his petulance about Chinese
taxes and he can't manage to keep his
[ __ ] ego out of these opaque but
essential balancing acts the ones which
stitched together the world as it is he
could get us all killed before his next
appointment with whoever or whatever
colors is god damned err resist peace